[Music]
back-to-school definitely means prank
time whether it's for your senior prank
or just for a little mischievous joke to
play on your friends you have to admit
that school pranks are the best pranks
stick until the end to find one of the
grossest but also most entertaining
pranks ever don't forget to hit that
like button and subscribe for more
videos like this one now grab your notes
and write down these 10 awesome pranks
for back-to-school Oreo prank Oreos are
absolutely yummy the cookie has actually
been crowned as the world's top-selling
cookie and we can totally see why the
current Oreo design has been present
since 1952 but the idea behind it has
been around since 1912 some of the most
unusual Oreo flavors include Oreo wafers
and the watermelon flavor as it's so
popular you can easily pull a pretty
mean prank on someone using the cookie
one of them is to glue the Oreo pieces
together with edible glue and remove the
filling from the inside a much better
trick is to also replace the filling
with toothpaste you can really trick
someone by presenting it as a mint Oreo
and they might not even know they've
been tricked take it to the next level
and make a challenge replace half of the
Oreo fillings with toothpaste and leave
the rest as they are it's like playing a
DIY version of the bean boozled
challenge we're really not sure how we
feel about that watermelon Oreo though
if you've tried it before let us know
what it tastes like in the comments this
cookie prank was inspired by the one and
only Michelle Tanner from the full house
who only enjoys the middle part of the
Oreos and we bet there are plenty of
more people who share her preference gum
just about everyone chews gum in school
and we bet you have at least one
classmate who has an endless supply of
gum and has to always give it to
everyone else if you're that person
there are a few innocent gum pranks you
can pull on your classmates that keep on
asking you for gum with the first you
don't even need to do anything other
than buying the product and we're sure
you've heard of it before
it's the electric shock gum so when
someone asks you for gum hand them the
packet and when they pull it out they'll
get a light shock
their finger don't worry as it's not
strong enough to cause any harm but it's
definitely hilarious
seeing the look on their faces another
option is to purchase one of these
cockroach gum pranks your classmate will
try to pull out the gum but instead of
the gum they'll end up with a very real
looking cockroach on their finger while
these prank gums have an unfortunate
name they definitely do the job and put
on a perfect show we bet you know at
least a few classmates you can pull this
prank on just remember to not get in
trouble with your teacher this prank is
also a fun one to test on your sibling
spicy pencil our next prank is one of
the most effective ones we'll show you
today we can imagine this happens very
often and just about everyone's guilty
of doing it if there's one item
everyone's always losing all the time
it's a pencil no matter how many you
have there'll be a point where you'll
lose them how many times have you
borrowed a pencil from your classmate
and found yourself chewing on it or
better yet how many times have you given
a pencil to someone and saw them chewing
it don't worry if you have because it's
something that happens everywhere we're
not sure what the fascination behind
chewing on pencils is but it does help
people concentrate there is something
you can do to combat it you can make the
pencil spicy using chilli or any other
spicy paste then just sit back and watch
as your classmate chews on it that'll
teach them for chewing on something
that's not theirs just be careful
because they might pull the same prank
on you later if you think the Spice
prank is a bit too mean having a pretend
rubber pencil might be a better idea it
looks exactly as a normal pencil but
it's in fact made of rubber and of
course it won't work when someone tries
to use it fake ice cream
who doesn't love ice cream it's totally
delicious and one of the best treats to
continue that summer feeling this is a
very fun prank to pull on your siblings
after you come home from school this
fake ice cream looks very real and it's
one of a unique prank you can pull
here's what you'll need to do grab a
bowl and mix in one pound of powdered
sugar half a cup of corn syrup and half
a cup of shortening then just mix it all
together until you get that ice cream
like an
Sisseton see you can use a pink food
coloring gel for a strawberry looking
ice cream and cocoa for chocolate these
definitely look incredibly real just add
a cone and voila there's your fake ice
cream if you don't have those
ingredients you can also make a similar
prey using mashed potatoes and gravy and
create a very real looking ice cream
sundae before you pull this prank make
sure you ask yourself how you would feel
if someone did this to you then go ahead
and do it anyways because it really is a
hilarious prank to pull on your sibling
and we'd love to see their reactions as
they realize they're not getting a real
ice cream make sure you have a real ice
cream backup ready just in case
cup prank if you really want to take
things to the next level and really
invest some time in a prank a cup prank
might be perfect for you this takes time
and patience as there are plenty of
things that could go wrong but it all
pays off when you see the look on your
friends face as they enter their room
and see the floor full of water filled
cups the concept is pretty simple get a
bunch of cups and start putting them on
the floor filling each with water make
sure you get any electronics out of the
way before and enjoy the aftermath of
your prank
check out the cup prank in action this
one was done in a school and we're very
impressed with the way the cups are
perfectly positioned this is one of the
most popular school pranks for seniors
but be careful because it could land you
in trouble
check out this very impressive hallway
full of cups that must have taken a
while to fill up we recommend setting
this prank overnight as it takes a few
hours to get it right but once you're
finished it really is a total
masterpiece what would you do in this
situation would you let the water spill
or just come back once someone cleans it
up post-it note prank this is one of our
favorite pranks there is it's creative
it requires an effort but the outcome is
really amazing it might take some time
but it's perfect if you're bored you can
do this in your dorm room or practically
anywhere we're glad that post-it notes
aren't expensive and allow us to get
creative with them sure they're used to
write down your to-do lists but people
have managed to turn them into some of
the funniest pranks ever we're sure
you've seen them people are covering
cars desks and entire rooms with Poe
stat notes here are some of our favorite
post-it notes pranks out there from
desks covered in post-it notes to an
entire house and even cars this is
definitely one of the most creative
pranks out there be careful of doing
this prank in school though because it
might just get you in trouble a couple
of high school seniors managed to get
themselves suspended for putting post-it
notes as their senior prank their prank
backfired when someone decided to
vandalize school property on the same
day we do recommend this prank as it
requires a lot of patience but it's
probably best to do it in your dorm room
or your house
airhorn chair prank we've seen this
prank in action several times and it's
without a doubt one of the most
hilarious pranks out there the concept
of it is very simple and you can build
this in just a couple of minutes what
you'll need are an air horn and a tape
you'll need to be very sneaky if you
want to do this prank at school or at
work and make sure the noise isn't going
to disturb too many people and get you
in trouble grab the air horn and tape it
vertically just below the cushion make
sure the trigger is set up the right way
up then watch as the person sits on the
chair their weight will lower the chair
just enough to trigger the air horn and
let out a loud noise that will
definitely make them jump once again
make sure this prank won't be too
disturbing for people around you as it
could get you in trouble if you do it on
the school ground however it's one of
the most perfect April Fools pranks you
can pull on an unsuspecting classmate or
a co-worker if you're doing this at work
make sure you get along with your boss
we bet at least one of you have been
pranked with the air horn chair before
gift wrap room ready to get crafty we
bet you'll love this prank much like the
post-it notes prank gift wrapping a room
is also a fun one to do as it requires a
lot of effort but the end result really
is spectacular this is one of the most
perfect pranks to pull on Christmas but
of course you can do this on any other
day - we've seen people use tin foil as
well as actual gift wrapping paper and
we're totally in love with them check
out these amazing rooms that got a gift
wrap makeover these people really went
out of their way and made sure every
single piece is perfectly gift-wrapped
this tinfoil room looks like something
out of a scary movie and is that a desk
wrapped completely in Justin Bieber
wrapping paper imagine pulling that
prank on someone who doesn't like Justin
Bieber at all this office took it to a
new level and turned this woman's
cubicle into a gift itself when we
totally love this car gift wrap prank
just make sure the person you're
targeting is not in a huge hurry because
we can't imagine it might take a while
to clean all this up we do wonder how
much money did all this wrapping paper
cost and who ended up cleaning up this
mess Macbook prank now this one is just
hilarious and you can do it in many
different ways have you ever wanted a
Macbook but you just have to give in to
the faith that you don't have one don't
worry you're clearly not the only one
we've tracked down some pranksters and
those who have been pranked by this
amazing laptop trick this person says
they came home from school and found
this on their desk they of course
thought it was a MacBook but it turns
out it was just a cleverly disguised
notebook with MacBooks being as thin as
they are you can definitely easily fall
for this trick this person asked for a
MacBook Air for his birthday and got an
underwhelming present of a Big Mac from
McDonald's a notebook and a bag of
crisps which we can assume is air there
seems to be no end to Apple jokes some
people are even taping an Apple to the
back of their computer as a joke to the
Apple logo there are thousands of
MacBook pranks you can pull on somebody
and they're all just brilliant of course
the most popular prank is the broken
computer screen you can use as a
wallpaper and pretend your friend's
laptop screen got smashed the options
are endless and we love them all fake
poop our last prank is probably the most
gruesome out of the ones we'll show you
today but we're pretty sure it'll have
the people screaming and running away
there are a few different ways you can
make a fake poop prank and really scare
off some people the first option is to
grab an empty toilet roll wet it and
squish it together so it resembles a
poop then just put it somewhere and
watch as your unsuspecting victim falls
for this trick you can also take it to
the new level and do this with water and
pet food then add brown paint and
everything in a plastic bag all you need
to do then is cut the tip of the bag
squeeze it and let your fake poop come
out it looks totally real and it's
definitely not a pleasant sight another
option is to buy one of these sticky
fake poop toys that look totally real or
make it with play-doh the options are
endless and we're sure you'll be able to
get very creative with this one you can
also buy one of these fart sprays and
take it to the next level just be
careful because you might end up being
pranked with this yourself and trust us
it's not a pretty sight what's the best
prank you've ever pulled on anyone let
us know don't forget to subscribe to our
channel and check out ten weird things
all kids do see you next time
[Music]